لطالما كان الفن حاضرا في جميع المحافل
الاحتجاجات في ايران الهمت فنانات في كندا
ليكن جزءا منها
باعمالهمكس
الفني ثلاثي الابعاد لهذا الشعر المقصوص
الذي جمعناه من اجل انعكس صمود المراه
الايرانيه التي تناضل من اجل الحريه
الحريه في التعبير ستكون الهدف من تصميم
هذا المشروع الفني
مصممه الازياء والمجوهرات ساره
ارتدته النساء خلال
عنده
اسالوني عما يحدث في ايران وهل من الممكن
ان اصنع شيئا يتم ارتداؤه ويكون توعيه لما
يحدث في ايران اول ما خطر بباله
ينزف من اذنها
كما قدمت عرض ازياء يعكس معاناه المراه
الايرانيه والقيود المفروضه عليها خالي
الايرانيين الى الانتفاضه الشعب الايراني
استخدمت مجموعه كنت قد عملت عليها قبل عشر
سنوات حول انتهاك حريه المراه وانتهاك
اجساد النساء
الايرانيه وشاهدناها رفعت في الاحتجاجات
المستمره حول العالم
[موسيقى]
الفنيه وتضامن الفنانين الايرانيون والغو
برامجهم وذو نوفمبر 2019 لانه بنظر
الفنانين فان هذه الايام اهم والاهم ان
طلاب الفنهم صوت الناس فاعمالهم الابداعيه
اصبحت الاحتجاج في الشوارع بدلا من صلاه
العرض
تفاعل قصه مساء مين مستمر عبر العالم وان
كانت قد تحولت الى ايقونه في بلدها لكن في
خارج الحدود وهنا في كندا حيث تعيش اكبر
جليه ايرانيه لفتت ماساه ماسا النظر الى
معاناه المراه الايرانيه
مختلف في الاحتجاجات لتعبر عن معاناه
المراه الايرانيه وتطالب بحقوقهن رفع
السعد العربيه تورنتو